such a game against mastodonten very
dangerous name from norway from
norway
so let's try it again with the
kalashnikov variant
i know only roughly that is now in the
c4 and springer 1 c3 is basically
like what comes on here now
i'm already over asked
no idea if that has a special
meaning
also the train jumper the five
i find the unpleasant one out i push the
market return jumper
so
maybe the cd sprenger ever 8 and
runner feeling to prepare
in bad runner to get rid of
longer break
yes if he so the  2 plays ok
doesn't work at all can play five
i can but maybe want to expect the
forerunner b6
that's good
yes of
course it looks a bit unpleasant optically
but of course it can also be easy
that these films are so stranded so
an active move would now be fulfilled
or maybe I'll only
cover the c7 square at about 8 and
can I also do d  pull a springer more comfortably
ok but half a half
025 that's a good idea
the 65 lasts a bit long also
looks a bit dangerous a
solid move would be springer apple 6
somehow attacks him
you can of course also
look comfortably but
the constellation here I have to  already
try something here ok not 35
that was to be expected
so now recognized a bit swapping away
it's worth taking 413 maybe
you're going to look stupid maybe springer 11 6 kat he wants to swap everything that moves
one of the ideas of what with  to hit the tone and
then maybe
the sixth one to do something here too
if he plays the 5 with it yes I have
now if we can't think of anything else
innsbruck runner simply e3
do it
like this the structures should actually be
resistant
can't be like that  an awful lot of people
are doing now i still have this
weakness
and
that shouldn't be enough to get something
tangible  res get out
so & black still has
a few chances
it was exactly when this bishop
pulls then I can do it at 5
so
moment is not so
terribly much
try
to persuade
loosening exercises here at some point so king
647 I have king the themselves  welcome
there at least no further
yes after the sixth row I
have lost nothing more I'll do it right away for
11 6 11 7
look I can make some
progress
after that you called
but it doesn't work like that now but e4 is
interesting
maybe a trump card 3
or is that too loose i
already have it on the 5th
check
it looks like that but it looks
kind of dangerous
that is that is almost math itself is
that
the
martina springer e5 king
that is quite after one with which
you unfortunately have nothing yet
again with 6 games each 5
check
that is not always so
unbelievable
although he has tried everything here
so I have now we live like that
an awful lot of
time so have to step on the gas a bit
overall exciting position he has the
have
i have the keeper
and still take it so i look
i think we should
have chances on
the queenside jump here i can just about get the 5 again to
get here  cover
yes
forgot to play king 26 shame
pawn through
but so straight
but so straight but crazy that it was
n't checkmate yes somehow or her good
maybe it was good but i did
n't see it
let's see what the computer does yes i
have me i have  itself of
course not that easy
knight i5 king has five company
king h6 king f7 unbelievable
king f7
tune the six rook has three
and then the pressure on someone
he can't prevent
that it would be
ok so there was 1 not yet seen